good morning everybody this is a higher
grieve around from Stanford University
we're all delighted you've joined us
this morning for a conversation with
John Millie has Tony mentioned the
John's not only an accomplished engineer
but he's also very accomplished builder
of organizations he's founded his own
organization reactivity he's been the
CEO there and also replaced him sub
there with a successor then went on to
Mozilla and currently is at greylock I
can also assure you that in my
experience he certainly has been one of
the most well-read if not the most
well-read CEOs he reads close to a
hundred books a year and we were just
talking about some of the interesting
books that he was reading let's actually
get him involved straightaway in the
conversation jump thank you very much
could you begin by telling us a little
bit about what are the key milestones in
your career and what insights did you
blame if you will from those my style
sure well thanks for having me you know
used to read a hundred bucks a year now
that I have kids I read you know more
like three a bunch of pages from each
book so not many but gets in he know I
was an engineer here at Stanford so an
undergrad and what I really wanted to do
is build computers so local also like
the president john hennessy I wanted to
do faster and faster chips and probably
the biggest turning point of my my
career to that point then a bunch of
people helped me understand that it
didn't lay matter how fast computers
would go if nobody wanted to use them is
that that led me to be one of the first
one of the early students here let me
call human-computer interaction which
led to much as work at the design school
but is really about how do you make
computers that are in software running
service of humans and that was a big
change for me to what it was you know as
I grew up a very technical person like
building things in service apenas is key
and after Stanford I've worked at a
startup coming off trilogy we'll talk
about that whether to recruit I worked
at Apple for a little while when Steve
came back which is
Sea Dogs came back and then I ran my own
startup a little while montura we did
one thing and we pivoted to another
thing which is a hard and we will talk
about that a little bit a hard hard
experience but meaningful for me and
then part of the biggest of college for
not in my career is really running
Mozilla esposo Mozilla for a number of
years when we released firefox and 2004
ticklish before I got there and I i
joined and we grew it from about 5
million years about 450 million users
around the world so there's quite a
quite a fun thing and I've been an event
on them the investing sides last two
years and it could have been lucky to
work with some of the most interesting
companies in the world histogram and
Dropbox and somewhere I defined my just
following followed it up with this quick
question you know in this very
accomplished career um yes begin with
trilogy and Apple what lessons have you
loved about innovation from your early
informative experiences there yeah well
so so told you probably a little
explaining so how do I haven't heard of
it mike night at the trilogy it was
about 80 people and it was a one of the
hottest startups at a time when charts
weren't such a big deal trilogy in 1995
you know it but they weren't there were
stars like netscape and quicken but they
wanted wasn't a common practice to go to
go to chart up and when I got there and
we this is similar to Apple's and I
below described Apple but truly has
gotten stuck so they had built
themselves on one product it was around
sales configuration and they built this
culture up of 5060 people all oriented
towards that and the product has been so
successful that they've built all their
processes and culture around it and they
didn't quite know how to smooth how to
evolve on to the next product and so you
know Joe LeMond a Stanford grad when he
decided to do was hard a bunch of or
Stanford drop other than us but he
decided her a bunch of people all at
once to work on a completely different
product line and so he had big so you
know they were probably 80 people in the
company of the time Joe hard 50 of us
all 23 24 years old and said okay we're
going to go do something completely
the company's dunce a date still work on
this new product and he kind of left the
new 50 people kind of run head-to-head
at the existing team so he's trying to
break the culture brake the brake
getting stuck with this massive big
change and i think the largest at work
and it really changed the culture of the
place and changed a lot of assumptions
about what what worked and what didn't
Apple was interesting you know I was an
apple when I was student here in 1994
1995 and then I came back to be an apple
in 1997 and I think Evelyn 1997 was bad
times I think it's hard to remember this
now you know Apple was around like a two
or three billion dollar market cap
company it was trading at about the cash
we had on hand everybody assumed that we
were going to get bought by Sun and so
it was a really miserable time the apple
products hadn't innovated very good in a
long long time and so while i was there
1997 is when they decided to buy next
which you know we didn't really
appreciate at the time was it good it
was a sort of a nice story to get Steve
Jobs back in the company and have a
local homecoming on sauvie nobody really
appreciated that buying next would lead
an inside-out revolution not so
different than what we do the trilogy
but this outside force coming in and
suddenly taking over all the DNA of the
place and so you know I was there at a
time when things were a polemic on you
big and dumb and slow company and all
virtually every way it was still fun
you're still kind of living on the on
the some of the innovation of some of
the reputation and some of the sort of
swag or Apple have built up to the 80s
and 90s but it wasn't what an innovative
company anyway and so you know there
while he came back and you know he he he
changed the culture are almost
immediately by storytelling narrative
and giving people mission am I saying no
to a lot of things so I think both
trilogy and Apple what I learned is that
when you're when things are going in a
bad direction what you really want to do
is make large changes to fix things
which raises an interesting question if
when things are going really bad
in a large changes matter what about
when things are going really well yeah
yeah so attention so thank you and I
guess I should say they told you the
things weren't going bad we just knew we
were getting a stock an apple things
were legitimately going back hmm Apple
wasn't it wasn't a very fun place other
than it was that it was you know the
cafeteria was pretty good in 1997 um but
um into you when things are going well I
think these really start to look for
compounding benefits so you start to
look for you know as you start to scale
you're scaling organizationally or
scaling users or you're scaling
influence them small wins so small
changes day to day they start to
compound day to day week to week month
to month you know when Instagram was
trying to grow like a very very small
change in their product would lead to
you know more users joining you know
every week and so and then the effects
compound is a network effects ebook 10
especially in today's world where
everything is so connected so network so
they're requiring to compact bingham in
terms of compound interest is key so I
think you know when things are not going
well big changes matter when things are
going well small changes matter but it's
a funny thing because in a lot of ways I
think small changes are trickier for
people to notice as hmm is a leader CEO
I've come to think that the main job
that the number one job with the CEO is
to be the storyteller in chief and to
talk about the narrative and help you
understand the reasons why the company
is doing what it's doing to you which
try to do is help people make decisions
on their own and people don't when
you're the CEO you tell the story so
often that you can say oh well this is
my this is my version a and this is my
slightly different nuance version B but
most people won't hear the new laws and
so at CEO it's easier to make big
changes like you know like Marissa's
doing the yahoo now our mega is doing an
HP that is make small changes a lot of
it
we heard because the small changes don't
get noticed right and you know our theme
of course is how do we prevent the
company from being big and dumb and you
you know hinted that they mentioned what
happened that trilogy and suck me an
apple why do companies become done when
they become big yeah you know more sense
um is it is coming to configure an
orange organization it's bigger I think
what happens is the number of
connections inside the company number
activities inside the company start to
potentially overwhelm the directors
customer things because more this you
can start to fill up your calendar with
internal linear small company when
you're five or ten people you almost
can't do anything except for have more
customer touches than internal touches
there's only so much you can do with
other people in the room and so I think
by nature you're focused our there's way
way more people outside and then as you
get a trip to get groups that are bigger
groups that are 5 or 10 or 20 people and
organizations that are thought you know
fifty or hundred or a thousand people
suddenly you can start to because you
start to build processes to make sure
that you have a lineman inside and you
start to see you try to have internal
action start to overtake external action
so I think a lot a good sign that you're
becoming a little bit thumb is when
people have more internal meetings than
they do thinking about their customers
and so a lot of times we would talk it
in Mozilla where we were clearly in
Firefox we were talking about you know
this is a great meeting to have it's
good to good to get a line just to talk
about talks to our differences but you
know is any of this really helping us
make a good browser for actual human
beings figure you add or your cousin or
your mom or whoever mm-hmm and I think
that having clarifying questions like
that and really understand why
understanding why you're in business
it's not to have your internal you know
configuration alignment symmetry synergy
meeting to get to build good products
for customers or so being able to tell
your story in a way to let you cycled
back to that all the time
key-soon is the calendar of a chief
executives sort of like a blood pressure
monitor if you will of individuals you
can look at somebody's calendar and
quickly say hey this is only pathway to
becoming done when this isn't coming
yeah well I don't think so CEO I think
that um as a CEO I I always thought my
job was to try to help other people be
external and obviously this I think
different leaders are different some and
some are going to be extremely focused
by nature some of the internally focused
and manager oriented I always thought
like my job is to help people understand
the trade-offs are making inside and
outside and so my calendar was always a
pretty good mix of external and internal
things I did what you did is you if you
go to observe companies though it's
pretty easy to tell whether they are
spending more time just sort of navel
gazing and thinking about things
together or externally yeah just kind of
dependent on the organization but
rhythms report rhythms are important so
as we sort of transition to the next
question and can you tell us a little
bit about the other things that you did
it mazuma yeah to prevent organizations
from big becoming big and dumb and here
perhaps would a distinction be valid
between them was stupid and dumb biz
sort of silent and huge yeah I mean I
think that if I wouldn't call them dumb
I think their organizations as they get
older they become less effective and
more susceptible to being beat by
smaller like small focus companies and
obviously that's my point of view from a
venture capital investing point of view
is far from you in Silver Valley you
know my sense is that you really want to
understand why you're growing and why
you're scaling and I think
organizational scaling I think some
people view it as a it's a thing is the
reason you're here in business I've
never thought that I think that impact
in the world or understanding
understanding what you're trying to
scale is the key for Mozilla you know we
had a number of things we were trying to
scale and what brought that wasn't the
traditional thing we weren't trying to
scale revenue we were trying to scale
influence and at a global scale so we
were trying to make the browser world
better and the department's pretty bad
and we knew we had a number of
components to that we had developers and
we were open source projects we had
community members we had users we had
web developers and understanding which
things needed to scale in which ways was
pretty key you know from so for us one
of the things they always thought about
was a leverage ratio so sort of for each
employee of the company how many
community members were we enabling to do
work in the broader context how many
users were we enabling and i think i
think these leverage metrics are pre key
to understanding what's happening is you
as you switch because you're getting big
especially on the internet use these
systems about 10 or 50 or 100 or some
billion users now it's they'll always
carry themselves in momentum and so the
user user action is almost always a
lagging indicator whether you're scaling
or whether you make whether you're
scaling what are making mistakes and so
what you're trying to do is find metrics
to tell your canary in the coal mine so
to give you hints that you need to
change well before you see it in user
metrics and for us it was all about
leverage of the community because I was
sort of it was a projection for us
people who were inside the company to
the people who felt connected with the
organization so you know for us but the
tools we had there are a bunch of things
we'll talk about sort of rhythms and
pasting Zinna second um for me the more
that have been while the startups the
more I start to think about the
importance of vocabulary and alignment
and you know we already talked about
storytelling there is any story tellings
importance because every organization
every entrepreneurial organization wants
to change the world
one's understand what the world looks
like when they win and and the best ones
remember that they can see the future
but nobody else can see their future yet
and so what you want to do is
continually tell the story about what
the future looks like and why it matters
and then tell them not for the story to
employees or customers or partners or
you know other people to help them
believe in sort of support the mission
from here to there and because one of
the things that when I is the CEO you're
my daughter place myself is my name is
my seat as CEO my start up when he's a
TI he taught me a lot about was
vocabulary in the alignment of
vocabulary because you know he would
keep it like a 22 you got HP and I been
a struggle guy started punk all my life
I guess and he comes in and you talk
about things and the first year was a
funny funny here because he had a bunch
of ideas and I they were not exactly the
same as my ideas inside pretty sure he
tried to fire me for five times or he
would have liked to farming but the and
then what we realized at the end of that
year is that on a lot of things who are
talking about the same thing that using
different work and or using different
using the same word planted for things
and one example is we were talking at
this meeting I remember we were talking
about well in the short term this is
important he asserted something I'm like
are you got to be kidding me in a short
term that's not a part at all this other
things important but we realized it when
he meant shorts are human DNA 18-month
roadmap and when I spent said short our
event like tuesday and so like into once
you figured out that vocabulary was
different and you start to a lot of
vocabulary and you could you could start
to ask questions to understand what each
person is doing either start to build a
line it back up and I sort of think I've
come to believe that storytelling and
vocabulary is key for billing alignment
and that alignment is key in an
organization which trying to do is every
organization that's doing interesting
steps moving faster than is comfortable
they're all you're trying to grill or
more more quickly than comfortable
you're trying to be a market a little
more quickly you're trying to release
product more quickly and so we should
try to do is get as many people able to
make as major
they can in ways that are consistent and
having it they're not always what you
and me sometimes are surprising and good
but you're trying to kind of reduce the
time that the decisions are surprising
back but in order for people to do that
they come have to understand the story
that's understand the mission and since
10 kind of where you're trying this
vision of the future that's me you know
one of the talks I give our game at
Mozilla was called poetry and pragmatics
and and I talked about the the poetry of
organization it's it's the lyrical it's
the it's the it's the sea aspirational
story and Mozilla the story was we want
the technology be open we want people to
be able to build technology not wait for
Larry Page to drop it or Steve Jobs to
drop it or her Bill Gates we wanted
people to be participating and hack
hacking was the poetry the pragmatics
were a little bit different so the
paramedics were well we do believe in
that but there's some keys to how we
actually run on how we make decisions
and to understanding the difference
between poetry and pragmatics an
organization and then understanding the
pragmatics can go out of alignment a
little bit for a little bit of time but
if you get out of line it for a long
time then use it through a problem so I
really come to think about the chief's
job against storytelling alignment
trying to help people understand the
prioritization stack to make us each
other so here's an interesting question
when companies become big in more stock
what do you mean with do you lead with
boy play first or do you need with
pragmatics so yeah I think I think
there's well like i said i think you
have them in when when things are going
well and you're you're you're
compounding the winds as you go along
you can make small wins and do very well
but I said let's make a big change okay
I think a lot of times you have to do
you have to leave in poetry I think you
have to remind people why they're there
there's a lot of times you know trip
he's you know from from Stamper here
wrote a book called stories Nick right
and and in every organization that got
that has got an interesting point has
along the way told stories that are
sticky they catch and they
the imagination employees or the kitchen
imagination of customers will have you
and that when things are going bad the
problem is those stories they might have
beer Eliam anymore but they're still
sticky and so you haven't changed the
story and you know they the most
illustrious when Steve getting back to
apple and yeah I'm focus a little i'm
blown but you know it it was a bad time
for apple and michael dell at the time
with his naps i share what her college
app will do with lip next he's a walking
they should close shop and get all the
money back so their shareholders that's
the responsible is what L said which is
interesting given what he's going to now
and so in the Steve came back and he let
a town hall where he's talked about what
you talked about whether we're doing it
said look we're going to build some
great products and we're going to change
the world with here if you're part of
about that let's get off let's move on
with it if you're not then get the hell
out and then something ask about with
Michael Dell said and steve zanter was
Michael Dell that's exactly what he
said I'll say that's what are you like
everybody in that room would have
followed Steve off a cliff and that day
because he had just changed an area of
so well from being kind of this big
sclerotic company that hadn't been doing
much to but we're going to go change the
world and nobody's gonna believe it
that's fine but all that's important is
what we do if you believe it let's go
and if you don't we don't need you until
you change it to an usher them narrative
very very quickly I guess probably it's
probably most powerful for single
leadership and some of my career Liam
clear yeah looks like to move to the
next important question since you have
designed top management teams and then
you know venture capitalists you
evaluate them how do you build and
manage a top team that's trying to scale
Wow you know I like the Stanford
football team picture it slide but how
come I think it's how do you how do you
help people make decisions like that so
it's it's how do you help people try to
get a little ahead of the obvious might
revisit that I tedder lagging indicators
use your growth across Maghreb how do
you get them as early as possible to see
what you'll need to change over time
there's yeah I think that's okay let's
come to the question of ribbons and then
you know maybe what we do is we've been
talking about scaling and ribbons so can
you share a couple of ideas about what
is rhythm and why is that important to
assisting successfully scaling yeah I
think where there's a great word I was
excited to see order to talk about it
you know for us I just a few different
things number one that you're trying to
teach you're trying to teach
organizations how to think about the
changes they want to see in the world
and think about how to measure
themselves and think about how to make
promises to each other so his
organization scale you get different
groups for you a different process parts
of the parts of the puzzle and you need
to be able to communicate and you meant
to each other and so building in daily
weekly quarterly monthly yearly sort of
rhythms and being able to say here's
what we're going to do here's where I
need help here's where I'm not sure
what's happening and then being able to
kind of follow up on that and say well
here's what we did here's what we didn't
do and you're trying to go in rhythms of
accountability I things what I'm saying
hmmm where those are promised and
rhythms of accountability so you're
trying to say here's what we're going to
do here's how we did here's what I think
one of you next week next next next time
and have people start to raise their
hand in a way to say that doesn't make
sense to me or I need help or manage so
I think they're huge I think there's
some that are calendar rhythms and just
like just like papers in school there at
some level they're designed to force
action so designed to make sure that at
least every quarter people pull
all-nighters get everything done some of
your trying to generate activity it's
somewhat we were trying to just keep
people honest and thoughtful and
reflective about what happened and give
time period and then there's other sort
of milestone based things and more
technology and process things it may not
be calendar-based rhythms but being
paying attention is celebrating when
things happen whether they're on a
schedule or not that I think that kind
of rhythm is those good good practice as
well so in this case on the rhythm you
mentioned daily weekly monthly quarterly
what's which one of those is a good
leverage point yeah but either all i
think the Opera important so you know I
think that what I found as a manager is
that people are pretty good about
setting daily things like the you can
come in the morning and it's not hard to
teach people to say well here's the maze
you have to do today make sure you have
done that but is right to dilate that
time period it gets harder to be honest
at yourself and so even though we even
have a weekly level like you know I have
bad weeks it's a little bit hard to
endure what I did you start to look back
and say oh well let's see what I did and
so you're trying to try to get people
used to looking back at the week and
saying well here's what I did here's
where I fell down here's where I was
wrong in my assumptions and you're
trying to heal the ton of critical eyes
their own time hmm and even in a weekly
scale I think that if you don't build a
discipline of practice round on that you
get a little bit lazy hmm and so so
building up that accommodated for
yourself and sometimes but when you what
I did a log is I just said well within
each crew puts in around weekly updates
and you'll sure feel weekly and it's
just are having to articulate or other
people helps you understand what's
happening but then when you send it to
monthly or quarterly it becomes even
harder to think about so what you're
trying to do is develop tools so that
people start to feel like what it
started us really acute sense of what it
feels like when you're at the end of the
period and you didn't get as much
accomplished as you wanted to
and you and you have to model that by
feeling let it sit like that on a day or
the week or the month to the quarter and
so is you develop more and more people
able to think longitudinally like that
you start to be able to set more more
organizational goals and you actually
hit it takes the longitudinal version of
alignment as Yeller so what are the
symptoms that the country is scaling too
fast or too far if there's such a thing
it's over scheming and so sure how do we
know that yeah well so I think it's
really really hard to see why you're
doing it I think the most scaling most
most things that are going really well
feel really feel like the wheels are
going to come off the place while you're
scaling it hmm and so I think almost
everything that's that you're taking
you're making the most of the
opportunity feels really Jenky and
really scary is feeling it and so I
think that you know my sense is it is
hard to tell what is going too fast and
so you try to help these metrics like we
were talking about these leverage
metrics or whatever but these are all
these are all reflections so they're not
they're not primary data there you're
trying to see out of the corner of your
eye where the pager kind of holding
together or not Russ and Mozilla was
about you know is it are we in abling as
many community members as we used to and
so understanding ratios and things like
that is a way to get to get early and
then being honest with yourself about
whether those really were were the right
metrics in practice was easily tends to
be tended to to teach to the test drive
yes that's right that's exactly the case
okay now perhaps this is a good juncture
for you to very close and very quickly
close on a couple of warning signs if
you will I mean you know when do you
know that the red lights on yeah but
this is one that we were talking about
is very beginning which is if you find
people are more interested in internal
they are and customers so you have more
people talking about you know group to
group communication or groups we warfare
and you have people talking about who's
actually using your product that's a
pretty that's a pretty good indicator
some are but maybe the best indicator
that's are they telling sign a Ziggler
Oh at this stage let's actually invite a
bunch of questions I imagine you know
there are lots of questions that people
have and we want to make sure that all
of you get as much of a chance to have
some of your questions heard and for
John to respond to that but before we do
that if there's a short closing sort of
piece of advice you'd give to
entrepreneurs what might not be I mean
in a sentence or two you know oh you
know I already said well by just doing
things are interesting to me and you
need that I like and not trying to not
trying to spread sheet it or try to
figure out what I should be doing so
going off and find the people in this
stuff that I like and I mean that's a
that's the best our charity that I'm in
my experience so here's an interesting
question I'm a 20 year old entrepreneur
who was working on a starter but I find
it hard to find investors and the right
team members to execute an idea already
you suggest I begin um but for the
million-dollar question I think that it
all depends on where you are and what
you believe in and what what title
company are working on I think that what
I would encourage you to do is to be
active to the active online to tumble
and tweet and blog and talk about which
what you're doing as many people as
possible and then so you can build a
building mentor network so you know I've
been very lucky or lucky to get this
advice when I was probably 22 which is
just go quite as many mentors as you can
and start to build that Network up and
over time what happens you start to ask
you for help
I too will say yes so a lot of times
people you've never met when you ask
them for help though to say yep I have
time give you new coffee at five thirty
or coffee at ten at night or coffee on
Tuesday morning or whatever it is and a
lot of people say yes and then you start
you to start asking questions and you
try to be aggressive about asking for as
many people to engage you can and then
over time you start to build up your
networking we know because a live thing
it's it's not a linear process so you
can I can't give you an answer on how to
go from here to you know being drew
Houston writing Dropbox you know
directly but what I can say is that you
start to pull on strings and you'll pull
on strains you'll find some unexpected
things and as you if you go in with an
attitude of learning and engaging and
trying to be as helpful as you can for
other people I think over time you start
to go to network go it'll they'll give
you the people you need let me give you
the people you need a couple of fun
another interesting enough question is
how do you address employees who
consistently thing to meet the metrics
in terms of productivity and leverage if
you will you know yeah well I think
there's like a few different schools I
think a lot of people say we look at
they don't go there if they're
consistently failing you've got you got
to move them out i need a pop and true
you know my experience I think when you
hire somebody when companies make a
commitment to employees just like
employees within two companies i think
there's there's some there's some
threshold that if if people are trying
hard i think it's incumbent upon you as
a as a leader use a manager to try to
figure out to try to try to debug that
relationship a little bit if it's not
working it was not one consistently that
nobody likes it like Robbie doing what
they're doing I did you know a lot of
times I when I let people go they finish
leaves I have to make that break and
move on although it's not never been
easy but sometimes it's just been people
the wrong seat where we didn't really
understand what they were trying to do
and they didn't really understand
ization and so going in with a an
attitude of debugging the problem and
the employee coming with a growth
mindset and the employer coming in
saying let people can change people can
grow that is worth that kind of
discussion once or twice and trying to
help sometimes it's the people are
uncomfortable being measured on a roll
of metrics and sometimes you just have
to help them understand it's not it's
not a terrible thing to be measured and
once you measure it you can make things
better mm-hmm so here's a very
interesting question about poetry and
rhythm the question is you talked about
poetry and the rhythm of business what
fostered your interest in humanities in
relation to a business culture in the
you know if I could just add a follow-on
when you began as the you know top
flight computer science engineer here at
Stanford would you even end this such
that you'd be talking about the
importance of poetry well so I was not a
top by computer scientist and I am NOT
now I was a media for computers eyes but
I tried hard um so um I don't know I see
a question like I in truth I don't like
poetry is per se so what would I really
want to try to find I've always felt
like the split between how you when I
was at Stanford to the number of classes
around sociology and Carter science and
but often I also really like classics
like language such a German and Latin
and and for me how he communicated sort
of key so how to communicate is not
necessarily a humanity is saying and how
we and how we make money how to Sara Lee
a business thing we're trying to do and
I think I think this stuff all coming
back it's coming he's getting better
integrated now with guys like Danny
reality and Daniel pink is immortal or
common Thomas where we've hard to say
look like but let's understand a little
bit better about why people do what they
do and how they're motivated and all I
would say is that mostly people are
motivated by numbers on a spreadsheet
you know that I remember when I was it
Mozilla which is a non-profit which most
people don't know
business schools would come in and we
talked a little to do and you know
invariably you know some second-year
would raise your hand and say well how
do you give you all to work here for a
non-profit like why don't want they want
to go make a gajillion dollars at Google
or Facebook and and the funny thing is
like you say well how many decisions
have you made yourself in the past week
or month or a year and he say in the
well made hundreds or thousands right
they say well how many of those was
economic gain to the most important
criteria and almost what never almost
always is none mmm people don't make
people you need to make money and you
want in often but there's lots and lots
of reasons you make make decisions or
self-worth or impact in the world or
because it's interesting to you or just
really might be fun and understanding
why people make decisions and not
treating it like it's purely an economic
decision I think ironically is often
times the way to the best economic team
so anyway so I think that going after
money directly is almost never regulated
blood of a product hmm but building
related product almost always is to way
to to kind of work your way towards the
best economic outcome so I don't know
I've never thought about that kind of
humanities versus business split always
said it's all about how humans work
that's a wonderful note to end the
question period and I'm going to turn it
over now to and really again thank you
John okay well thank you very much
professor oh and John you live for
sharing this morning with us you
provided some great insights and again
thank you for your for your time